hello my name is reto Meier and welcome
to a special extend edition of this week
in Android development
featuring what's new in Android 4.3 last
week was a big one for Android with the
release of the newest model Nexus 7
measuring almost two millimeters thinner
and 50 grams lighter than its
predecessor
it also features surround sound 5.1
front and rear facing cameras a 1.5
gigahertz processor 2 gigabytes of
memory and a 1920 by 1200 resolution
display all this and it confers a +3 to
both public speaking and asking our
girls if your apps aren't optimized for
tablets now is a good time to get
started but the real news for developers
is the release of Android 4.3 in
addition to the inclusion of even more
butter it includes support for
restricted profiles OpenGL ES 3
Bluetooth Low Energy and improvements to
media accessibility and performance
analysis let's take a closer look at
some of these new API s profiles builds
an e multi user user functionality
introduced in Android 4.1 allowing you
to create sub profiles that include
system-wide and app specific
restrictions that means your app can
declare restriction entries including
boolean flags choices and multi select
choices like this single choice
restriction entry each of which can
specify ways that your apps
functionality can potentially be
restricted your app will then appear in
these system settings where each of
these restrictions you defined will be
available to the device owner they can
select their preferences for your app
for each of their restricted users to
apply those preferences to your app at
runtime
simply check for a bundle of restriction
settings associated with your app by
query the user manager when you're a
presumes as shown in this code snippet
you can find out more about supporting
restricted profiles from rich hyneman's
dev byte also new to Android 4.3 is
platform support for Bluetooth Low
Energy ble support allows you to build
apps that interact with the latest
generation of small low-power devices
and sensors that use Bluetooth smart
technology to communicate the ble API is
used this workflow to interact with
supported devices you start by scanning
for nearby devices then manage
connections discover available services
and query and monitor characteristics
provided by connected devices you start
by scanning for ble devices calling
stylus scan on the phone's Bluetooth
adapter the scanner is also reported
using this less scan callback callback
they reports any detected devices a
received signal strength indication and
the inverter sment data describing the
services available from that device you
can then connect to that device using
its GATT server using the call connect
gap method implementing the Bluetooth
Gap call back to receive connection
results and one of the available
services and characteristics you can
then read and write those sensor values
and request notifications whenever a
particular characteristic changes your
app can work as either a client or a
server and can transmit and receive data
in either mode
the API is a generic so you'll be able
to interact with a variety of devices
including proximity tags watches Fitness
meters game controllers remote controls
and help devices for more details on
Bluetooth Low Energy and using these
api's in your app check out this dev
byte from our ble expert Fred Jung we've
also introduced Java interfaces and
native support for OpenGL ES 3 so games
and other apps with high performance 2d
and 3d graphics are now fully supported
by the underlying graphics hardware
OpenGL ES 3 includes many improvements
including these that support the
creation and complex but efficient
graphics that work across a range of
devices using a single texture
compression format there are also a
number of enhancements to Android's
media stack starting with a modular DRM
framework that makes it easier to
integrate DRM into your preferred
streaming protocols such as MPEG DASH
the new media DRM class is a module
solution that separates DRM from media
playback so for example you can playback
Widevine encrypted content without
having to use the Widevine media format
the media DRM API is should be used in
conjunction with the mediacodec api is
that we're introduced in android 4.1
including media codec for encoding and
decoding your content media crypto for
handling encrypted content and media
extractor for extracting and de-mux in
your content support for vp8 encoding is
also now available as framework and
native API for a range of four
the FBI's includes support for setting
target bit rate rate control selecting
frame weights token partitioning area
resilience reconstruction and loop
filters back in Android 4.1 the
mediacodec class introduced support for
low-level encoding and decoding of media
but it required that it be provided as a
byte buffer array in Android 4.3 you can
use a surface as the input to an encoder
so you can encode input directly from an
existing video file or using frames
generated from OpenGL es2 use the
surface as the input to an encoder call
configure on your media codec object
followed by a call create input surface
to receive the surface upon which you
can stream your media the beginning
coding call start on the media codec and
went down call signal end of the input
stream to terminate the encoding before
releasing the surface the media MUX a
class enables multiplexing between an
audio stream and a video stream it's
designed to work primarily with media
codec so you can perform video
processing using media codec and then
save the output to an mp4 file using the
media moxa the media Maxo can also be
used in combination with media extractor
to perform media editing without the
need to encode or decode currently mp4
is the only supported output format and
the media moxa supports only one audio
stream and one video stream at a time
the first jellybean release allowed
media players to offer playback controls
from remote control clients like the
lockscreen ongoing notifications and
Bluetooth remotes this was all done
using the remote control client API now
these applications can also display
playback progress and handle jumping to
a specific playback position via
scrubbing if you're already using the
remote control client API s then you can
add support for scrubbing by enabling
the flag key Media position update using
the set transport controls flags method
on the remote control client and this is
going to make the scrubber visible then
implementing both an on get playback
position listener overriding the on get
playback position method to return the
current position of your media and an on
playback position update listener with
an overridden on playback position
update method to listen for a new
timecode when the user scrubs the
playback using the remote control UI
with these interfaces defined you can
then set them on your remote control
client by calling set on get playback
position listener and set playback
position update listener a new UI
automation framework uses the
accessibility service API is to support
testing interact with the devices UI by
inspecting the screen content in
injecting arbitrary keyboard and touch
events you can also perform system UI
actions like hitting the back button or
at hitting the screen and even taking
screenshots best of all the UI
automation API is work across
application boundaries to get an
instance of the UI automation call
instrumentation get UI automation within
your instrumentation test case you can
then perform tests by creating events
and injecting them into the message loop
and confirm the results by introspecting
UI elements you do this by obtaining the
root accessibility node of the UI and
searching for the screen element you
want to inspect either by name or by ID
execute your tests using the adb am
instrument command specifying the - w
flag package name and test runner
next up the systrace tool has been
improved to make it easy to provide more
ways to profile the performance of your
app you can now collect trace data from
hardware modules kernel functions the
dalvik vm including garbage collection
resource loading and more Android 4.3
also introduces the trace class with the
new static methods begin section and end
section which allow you to define
specific parts of your code to include
insist trace reports so you can get a
much more detailed analysis of where
slowdown occurs within your app the
there are also new developer options to
help you analyze performance and spot
rendering issues the profile GPU
rendering option lets you visualize your
apps effective frame rate on screen you
can choose to display profiling data as
on-screen bar or line graphs with colors
indicating time spent creating drawing
commands blue issuing the commands
orange and waiting for the commands to
complete in yellow the on-screen graphs
are updated continuously showing a graph
for each visible activity as well as the
navigation bar a notification bar a
green line highlights the 60 millisecond
threshold for rendering operations so
you can see your apps effective frame
rate relative to a 60 fps
there are also improvements to
internationalization including new
utilities and api's for creating better
RTL strings and pseudo locales to make
it easy to test your apps localization
accessibility services can now observe
and filter key events so they can handle
keyboard shortcuts or provide navigation
in parity with gesture based input and
apps can now define the exit and entry
animation types used on a window when
the device is rotated you can set window
properties to enable jump cut crossfade
or standard windows rotation look for
more information on changes to the UI
including those animation changes from a
chat near you just in time for Android
4.3 the support package action bar API
now at last is available find out all
about how to integrate this critical
piece of the Android design language
into your app from this devbyte from our
very own Chris Bane's when we weren't
busy launching new jelly bean flavors we
were busy in our studio Ankara is
releasing the fourth part of his
five-part series on making apps
beautiful this time looking at
performance tuning Chet meantime returns
with the highly anticipated second part
on his series on anticipation and on the
app clinic last week I used Cricut apps
as an excuse design my own version of
the perfect sports tracking act my
artistic skills are roughly on a part of
the Australian top orders batting skills
so I devoted most of my session to
strategies for minimizing latency while
maximizing battery efficiency if your
app needs frequent updates but you don't
want to drain the battery check this one
out our design advocates will be taking
my amateur mocks and turning them into
something more inspirational on
tomorrow's episode of Android design in
action as always you can go to
developers.google.com slash live slash
Android to see what we've got planned
for ADL this coming week the release of
Android 4.3 also saw a flood of new and
improved apps to Google Play including
Beauty and the Beast with restricted
profile support a run tusk-tastic update
that supports Bluetooth Low Energy
Netflix updated to provide 1080p HD
video and games such as galaxy on fire 2
monster shooter 2 prince of persia'
shadow and the flame and Riptide gp2
from vector unit we'll be back next week
for more of what's new in Android
in the meantime that's all for our
special what's new in Android 4.3
edition thanks for watching and remember
that these Saiyans fall into my mind